[Music]
this morning on the dish rising star
chef Whitney Ataka raised in a small
town in California's Mojave Desert she
earned a degree in anthropology before
deciding on a cooking career she's had
jobs at some of the nation's top
restaurants but fell in love with
Southern cuisine while working in Athens
Georgia now she makes her home not far
from there on Georgia's a rustic
Cumberland Island where she's executive
chef at the prestigious gray field in
and seaside cuisine is the subject of
her just-released first cookbook the
salt water table recipes from the
coastal south chef Whitney Otaka good
morning welcome to the dish every
morning great to be here this looks and
smells fantastic what do we have here
thank you I brought you a little taste
of the South East Coast starting on the
end there
we have buttermilk biscuits with a peach
and bay laurel JLo in the middle here we
have a very sort of traditional dish
it's fish shrimp and grits and we use
rice grits as a base as opposed to
traditional hominy grits next to it
there we have cast iron fillet beans
with a red pepper pepper rod and a been
a seed sprinkle on top right here we
have lovely fried oyster salad so trying
to make it a little more healthy with
some lettuces radishes milk dressing and
then right here we have a beautiful
grapefruit heart with chamomile cream
and often times we'll sprinkle a little
honey over that fantastic and then of
course the old man in the sea which is a
run bass dream grapefruit lime coconut
water and a little bit of salt mmm and
it's so good so I got to get to the
bottom of this you were studying at
Berkeley yeah and we you saw an ad in
the newspaper about a waitress job yeah
so I loved everything French growing up
as you know many many little girls do
and I was a Francophile and I saw an ad
for a waitressing position in Oakland
California little French Creperie which
I was like perfect I'm Amelie I'm going
to serving
beautiful food I went in and I applied
for the waitressing job
the owner is from Toulouse France you
can see clearly I had no waitressing
experience and he put me in the kitchen
with him which i thought was even more
brave than putting him before but he
really taught me so much about the
beauty of food the conversation of food
the shared table we would eat a meal
after every shift together and it was
just a lovely experience I fell in love
with restaurants and you can fall in
love where you work right now talk a
little bit about where that is yeah it's
Cumberland Island so it's basically the
size of Manhattan about 17 miles except
for there's 50 permanent residents
instead of however many I am live here
and it's a National Seashore designated
in 1972 I'm exposed to the nature of the
place every single day it inspires how I
choose to design the menus how I decide
to cook I'm outside I see things growing
wild things growing you know we have a
beautiful two acre garden that supplies
things so it very much influences how I
think about this so Whitney gets to work
on a national seashore and make amazing
food yeah yeah a little bit and gets to
work with her husband how does that go
because sometimes that can be a
challenge some people wouldn't say
that's such a lucky but for us it's
always worked we met working in
restaurants it's basically like having a
clone in the kitchen we think the same
we develop our menus the same way I
always have a sounding board to work off
of he's fabulous what's the biggest
challenge though to working here you
know I think that work never really ends
especially for someone like me that's
kind of a workaholic how we always carry
at home but we're always talking about
food so sometimes I step back and
realize how lucky that job is it's not a
terrible thing and what is it about
southern cuisine yeah it's you when I
moved to the South I was instantly
struck by the beauty of the cuisine the
history of the culture of the place
Agriculture's everywhere so I instantly
fell in love with it it's such a strong
food region so what is the dish that is
your favorite oh well that's just a
terrible question
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right now I I mean I was I always go
through waves with the biscuits well
lately I've been eating a million
biscuits
so maybe biscuits should be where
everyone should start with something I
enjoy as you sign the dish yeah if you
weren't gonna have this meal with anyone
past or present who would it be you know
a great influence on my writing and
someone I've always deeply admired was
Anthony Bourdain and when he passed it
was it struck me a lot and I realized
you know his voice always came to me and
I realized he really wrote in his off
time and made the time for it and it was
a drive for me so I would love to have
cooked for him in my life hear that name
yeah you signed that dish in chef
Whitney Ataka we thank you for being
here with us and if you want to know
more about Whitney or the dish as she
hands it to you go to the web site at
CBS this morning
dot-com